this could be the last time I ever see
the castle today is the day that we're
supposed to complete and we have another
money right now I'm not feeling
confident but that would that would
happen like if he says no I'm feeling
like this could even fall through and
I'm worried I don't think it gets much
more stressful mess but we weren't in
time we're not kidding when you not
gonna be able to complete in time so
this is make-or-break right now
depending on this conversation goes if
he says yes and work with us it's gonna
save everything if he says no we're
gonna be very screwed
[Music]
bad news unfortunately really bad news
the owner of the castle not only has he
said no he will not accept the offer of
Panks on now and then the rest later
he's also now served notice on us
so we've now just got a few days to
miraculously get the money together to
complete on the castle really annoyingly
if I'd have known this like I've got
money in my properties I could refinance
but to refinance it takes like six weeks
or so to actually get the money so it is
really difficult I'm really frustrated
about the situation and I don't get it
because it would have made great sense
for him to do that but I'm gonna be like
the aunt I often talk about the aunt and
aunt will not just turn back when
there's a problem an obstacle and that
will go round it it will go over it will
go under it will go through it so I'm
gonna find a solution and we're going to
get the money in time we're going to
complete I'm very confident it's just a
case of how right now so I think right
now I'm just gonna go to bed and have a
sleep and then first thing in the
morning we're gonna have an emergency
boardroom meeting and we're going to
figure a plan of how to get this money
in and how to complete in the next few
days so I definitely just sleep right
now
so I spoke to the owner as you know he
said no mm-hmm to let us pay someone
else another line
he also said notice on us yeah so we
need to mr. plunk page but the bottom
line is I wanted million today so I
think we just sell a couple of the
apartments within the castle sell them
off plan to two thousand pound each yeah
they're gonna be worth way more than
that down the line we pay for the refurb
the big advantage of that method yep is
that we don't have to worry about
[Music]
payment bridging finance or anything
like that yeah till it's the bridging
finance is well if for some freak reason
I think we should still try new the
bridging finance rapidly as well I think
we should just push I think we should
just do everything we got
I think we need to freaking make calls
right now pull our sleeves up and just
get some money in the bank so you can
complete yeah I put the whole Delft so
so yeah well you're free today I'm free
let's just do it let's go smashing man
so you can't obviously get the money
over it's gonna take a couple of weeks
yeah the problem is we need to move a
lot faster than that so I mean that's
why we give it away such a really good
deal okay no problem at all yep just
bear with me one moment Samuel this is
really really tough they're asking all
these questions
do you mind speaking them directly no
give me the names since we were about
five years old we went to school
together and I know there's anybody to
pull this deal off it's gonna be some
the leads okay have you got any other
questions for me right now
okay listen give me one moment Holt I've
got my other phone Graham one second
hello how's it go ma'am I'm good buddy
awesome
good decision man look forward to
working with you all right thanks so
much Cheers
so I've just checked we've now got
200,000 pounds in the bank we've also
got our own 400,000 pounds which means
that we're just 200,000 pounds short of
completing now you know what when you've
got such a fantastic team and also a
good proven track record a good brand it
shows the power of it because without
the proper contracts and stuff it's hard
so two hundred thousand pound more and
then we don't see what happens
[Music]
fantastic that's also yep so what I'll
do I'll I'll check the keep an eye on
the account and as soon as we seen the
money in that although took me an email
deferment it's all it's always safer
that's brilliant
fantastic it's gonna be a great deal for
both of us you take care thank you bye
okay both money in the bank all happened
thank you so much God and everybody for
all your support so now it looks like
it's just a case to drive to Wales get
it signed and completed I am happy jeez
that was stressful let's do this hi I'm
Sam Hawking I've known Samuel readers
for quite a while now we've just got
involved in his purchase of a fantastic
renovation so he's just with us now
signing the documents hopefully ready
for completion tomorrow the contracts
and we should be completing on the
castle tomorrow
fingers crossed boom here we go just got
back man I'm feeling good right now if
I'd have known that this would have
happened like a day or two ago I was so
stressed I worked so hard I grind it but
you know what it will come off now in
fact I've just got back I've had a
message off the bridging finance company
saying with baby that we need we can
release your funds over as well so we've
been getting all this private finance
coming in we've got four hundred
thousand but now the bridging company
said they can give us four hundred
thousand - it's like when you're waiting
for a bus and there's suddenly to come
along so right now if we wanted to we
could take the bridge in which will mean
that the property would be a no money
down deal and we can hold out half a
million back for part of the refurb so
many options I'm just absolutely
flabbergasted and overwhelmed with joy
thank you for your support thank you
guys for just cheering me on and Arnold
Schwarzenegger says no man is an island
and no one is self-made so thank you
guys for everyone's support god bless
you I'll keep you posted on the progress
thank you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time